&gt;&gt; If you took a break, welcome back. We've been talking a lot about lines and
slopes and intercepts. And well, who cares? What good are these lines and
equations anyway? It turns out we can use them. For example, let's say we're
moving and we need to rent a truck to haul all of our stuff. I looked up prices
to do this. And I found that doing this requires us to pay an initial fee of
$20, plus $2 per mile. So, if I don't drive the truck at all, I still have to
pay $20 just to get the keys. I'm going to list the dollar sign here, instead of
the table for each value. So, if we rented this truck and drove it one mile, it
would have cost $20 plus $2 for the extra mile. So that's $22 in total. Based on
this price structure, how much would it cost to drive the truck 2 miles, 3
miles, and 4 miles? Put your answers in each of these boxes.